all right you [ __ ] maggot welcome to
train school the first rule of train
school is always stand behind the yellow
line the second rule of train school is
there are no rules what about the first
rule the third rule of train school is
anyone who interrupts me gets a copy of
train simulator 2012 in the face now if
you think train school will be a walk in
the park
then you are a psychedelic [ __ ] mmm
are we being a bit dramatic for a school
where we learn how to drive trains oh I
see we have a smartass here do we have a
name smartass it's it is stuffy on them
well mr. Takayama a trained expert you
look like the kind of guy who thinks
taking a woman out means getting some
flowers wining and dining her and then
pissing all over her naked body
are you a pisser mr. Takayama wait are
you a pisser mr. Takayama what you think
all you need to do is pull a lever to
make a train move you think you could
just log 15 hours into train simulator
and be ready to go yes well there go and
practice pulling some levers and two can
jack off the god damn bull for everyone
else let's drive some [ __ ]
train train simulator [ __ ] [ __ ]
what you know train simulator pitch
watch that train go to the station yeah
I'm on time
ships when they pop on my butt damn damn
damn damn damn what are you guys doing
do you wish you a train might just came
out of garel damn girl damn girl damn
you're them girl goddamn Barbra must
have talked
ok so I know you've all just graduated
from train school but I've called you
here because there are some things about
your new jobs we have to go over firstly
soccer I've had some complaints about
you being overly violent at work a
little heated sometimes you should
mannequin a hundred and twenty seven
times in the deckhouse shoot you and a
dick if you don't shut up speaking of
which Takayama
I know parking space is low but please
find somewhere else to park your car
yeah where do you park your car oh it
should be and lastly not gonna name any
names show but whoever keeps taping a
giant spliff to the front of the train
to make it look high please stop
does not look funny and so forth behind
them now if any of you have nothing else
to discuss let's all get to work
whatever our jobs are hello can you
please tell me where the bathroom is oh
sure ma'am let me just wait I got this
hello it's nice to meet you I'm Takayama
Takayama watashi wa talking about this
ya speak another language that'll help
her understand you are you feeling hot
daijoubu do you need me to make you feel
kimochi she's oh that [ __ ] you idiot
well sue me my sense sakurai-kun I know
how to handle old ladies I I think I
just pooped my pants
do your job yes I can feel it dripping
down my legs the person that wears a
skirt that looks like it's crying up her
ass what us girls are gonna do our own
thing elsewhere and you better take back
about what you said about my ass
mmm-hmm stop looking at your erection hi
[ __ ] hate penises I mean men I hate
men they're all [ __ ] it's all their
[ __ ] isn't is contained in their
penis or something
ah yes I remember when I used to have a
penis it was a bit dangly in the p1
everywhere that I could play light saber
with it and at least I didn't some hand
woman whenever I needed one
that's adorable darling well it's
annoying
son of a [ __ ] I don't get it what a
girl's have an easy time dealing with
everything maybe it's cuz she's got
those two bombs under a chest yeah man I
think you're the bomb
no you da bomb no you da bomb we both
the bomb there's a bomb on this platform
what do you want us to do about it
defuse it you're not serious right
can you shut up for a second I've tried
to concentrate please tell me you know
what you're doing I have a basic
understanding of electronics and besides
in the movies it's always a choice
between the red and blue wire so we just
have to look for those there's no red or
blue wire wire I'm sorry the terrorists
weren't kind enough to put a big fat
label next to the wires saying hey if
you want to defuse this bomb please cut
this goddamn wire here okay okay sharp
at this point I know I only have one
wire left to cut this is this one that's
a ground wire well how about this one
that's two random wires I'm sorry I must
have missed the bomb is there anything
[Applause]
now whatever you do don't let the ball
drop
understood so what happens now well
thanks nothing [ __ ] don't worry I'm
still here I'm going to see if I can
find help you wouldn't leave me right
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you're on your own
[Music]